Guten Tag.
Atish ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Diensthabende arzttätig und würde mit Ihnen
diesen Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben oder etwas nicht verstehen, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Okay.
Sind Sie damit eigentlich verstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache jemand hilft mir.
Ja, ich habe starke Schmerzen.
Gut.
Ich werde jetzt ein paar persönliche Fragen stellen,
gleich zu Ihnen aktuell übergehen.
Darf ich Ihren Namen erfahren?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich heiße Natalia Kramer.
Natalia Kramer.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam beschreiben?
Ja, ja.
N-A-T-A-L-I-A.
Das ist Natalia und Kramer.
K-R-A Umlaut.
Also E-M-E-R.
Natalia Kramer. Frau Kramer.
Frau Kramer. Genau.
Frau Kramer, wie alt sind Sie und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 76 Jahre und ich bin am 4.8.1949 geboren.
49?
Okay.
Wissen Sie, wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, also in meinem Ausweis steht, dass ich 1,68 bin.
Vielleicht bin ich inzwischen ein, zwei Zentimeter kleiner.
Man schrumpft ja mit dem Alter.
Und ja, mein Gewicht weiß ich zu genau.
Ich wiege so ziemlich 80 Kilo.
80 Kilo?
Wie groß sind Sie mit der Ola Mitte?
1,68 Meter.
Okay, Frau Kramer.
Was wird Sie zu uns heute?
Wie können wir Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also ich habe mit einmal solche heftigen Schmerzen.
Also das sind...
Also das ist so im Rücken und zieht bis in den Bauch rein und
in den Rücken hoch.
Und es geht sogar bis in den Oberschenkel rein.
Also praktisch die ganze linke Seite, da tut es mir so heftig weh
und es krampft so richtig zusammen.
Und das sind...
Also so starke Schmerzen.
Das hat so ein bisschen angefangen vor zwei Tagen.
Und jetzt sticht es und zieht.
Also ganz übel.
Okay, ich verstehe, dass Sie zwei Tagen
Rücken Schmerzen mit linksseitigen Oberschenkel ausstrahlen.
Ja, und die Schmerzen sind krampfartig.
Sind? Krampfartige.
Ja, ja, genau.
Ja, und es sticht und zieht.
Und ja, und was mir auch aufgefallen ist,
also irgendwas ist mit dem Wasserlassen.
Also ich muss ständig auf die Toilette und es tut sehr, sehr weh.
Und es brennt.
Und ja, heute Nacht musste ich auch,
viermal bin ich aufgestanden, weil ich immer wieder das Gefühl hatte,
ich muss jetzt zur Toilette.
Und also jetzt, heute Nacht habe ich mich auch jetzt so schlapp gefühlt
und so schlecht, ich habe mit einmal gefroren und...
Also, ja, obwohl ich im Bett lag, war mir mit einmal eiskalt
und ich habe so gezittert und schlecht ist mir vor Schmerzen wirklich.
Okay, Frau Klemmer,
wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer numerischen Skala von 0 bis 10,
wobei 0 ist keine Schmerzen und 10 ist unerträglich Schmerzen bedeutet?
Unerträglich.
Also,
ja, wie kann man das beschreiben?
Das ist ein bisschen schwer.
Vielleicht so zwischen 6 und 7 oder so.
Okay.
Also,
ähm,
die Schmerzen außen oberchenkel in der anderen Körperregion aus?
Ja, eigentlich ist das so auf die linke Seite beschränkt, also auf
den Rücken, so auf die Seite.
Da tut es überwiegend weh, ja.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen vermindert oder starker?
Also, ganz starken Schmerzen habe ich natürlich, wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe.
Ja, aber das sind dann andere Schmerzen.
Das sind dann dieses fiese Brennen beim Wasserlassen.
Das tut richtig weh.
Und
dann habe ich eigentlich auch das Gefühl, dass es dann auch im Rücken gerade noch
mal schlimmer wird, ja, und wenn ich dann wieder im Bett liege und
wieder mich schön warm mache, habe ich das Gefühl, dass es ein klein bisschen
besser auszuhalten ist.
Und ich glaube auch, dass es im Liegen,
im Liegen ein klein wenig besser ist, als wenn ich jetzt rumlaufe.
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieberprogramme?
Also ich fühle mich tatsächlich heiß, aber ich habe mich nicht gemessen.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt,
Sie haben Schütterfrust.
Ja, also heute Nacht habe ich das vor allen Dingen.
Da war mir mit einmal ganz kalt und ich habe so gezittert und dann
habe ich mich schön warm zugedeckt und
ich war eigentlich zu schlapp.
Am liebsten hätte ich mir noch einen warmen Tee gekocht, aber ich war irgendwie zu
schlapp, ich konnte es gar nicht.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter
Atemnot oder Husten?
Nein, nein, nein, Husten muss ich nicht.
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzkopfen, Herzstorpein?
Nein, nein, ich habe nur diese Schmerzen beim, also im Rücken und beim
Wasserlassen, das ist richtig übel.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Wasserlassen Farbeveränderungen?
Das war es.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Wasserlassen
Farbeveränderungen gibt?
Also ich gehe ja nun alle
ständig auf die Toilette und was mir aufgefallen ist, dass das ein bisschen
dunkler aussieht als normal.
Okay.
Und es stinkt auch ziemlich übel, also es riecht nicht gut.
Stinkt.
Okay.
Wie häufig müssen Sie auf die Toilette gehen?
Also bestimmt häufiger als jede Stunde.
Also ja, also mindestens jede Stunde einmal.
Und in der Nacht ja, vielleicht so alle zwei Stunden.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stolgang?
Ja, manchmal bin ich so ein bisschen verstopft, dann muss ich so ein
Granulat einnehmen gegen Verstopfung, das hilft mir dann eigentlich immer ein
bisschen, aber also das nehme ich nicht regelmäßig.
Das nehme ich nur, wenn ich das wirklich brauche.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also im Augenblick ist er nicht gut.
Heute mochte ich nicht viel essen und gestern auch nicht.
Aber normalerweise schmeckt es mir eigentlich gut.
Ja, ich muss halt ein bisschen aufpassen, weil ich
schon ziemlich lange so einen Alterszucker habe.
Aber ja, eigentlich
also
habe ich das ganz gut im Griff mit den Medikamenten und da muss man ja auch
nicht so strenge Diät halten.
Also eigentlich schmeckt es mir schon sehr gut.
Ja, aber jetzt, wie gesagt, die letzten Tage war das nichts mit dem Essen.
Ich vermute, dass Sie nicht gut schlafen.
Nein, heute Nacht habe ich ganz schlecht geschlafen.
Wirklich. Aber normalerweise
geht es eigentlich, kann ich eigentlich schon ganz gut schlafen.
Ja, das ist jetzt nur so die letzten Tage, dass es wirklich übel war.
In letzter Zeit haben Sie bemerkt, Ihren
Gewicht abzugenommen.
Schön wäre es, wenn ich ein bisschen abgenommen hätte.
Aber nee, habe ich leider nicht.
Ihren Gewicht ist stabil, oder?
Bitte?
Stabil, oder?
Das ist, die harte ist immer gleich.
Ja.
Frau Krämer, ich möchte wissen,
ob Sie rauchen oder Alkohol trinken.
Ja, die sind ja.
Also ich rauche
ja inzwischen nur noch so eine halbe Schachtel am Tag.
Halbe Schachtel am Tag?
Seit wann rauchen Sie?
Schon ewig.
Also schon als junge Frau habe ich angefangen.
Und früher habe ich mehr geraucht.
Da habe ich eine ganze Packung am Tag geraucht.
Und ja, jetzt sind die ja auch so teuer geworden und so.
Und ja, jetzt also ein bisschen weniger rauche ich jetzt schon.
Also wie gesagt, früher ein Päckchen am Tag und jetzt
ja so vielleicht so seit
10 Jahren, 15 Jahren so, dass ich, dass ich nur noch ein halbes Päckchen am Tag brauche.
Okay, dann gibt es den Alkohol.
Ja, also ich trinke sehr gerne abends mal ein Glas Rotwein oder auch im
Sommer, wenn es warm ist, trinke ich auch gerne eine Flasche Bier oder auch mal,
ja, wenn es sehr warm ist, zwei oder so.
Und wenn es was zu feiern gibt, natürlich ja auch mal ein Glas Wein extra.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, aber das ist eine Routinefrage.
Hatten Sie oder haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen?
Nee, also das habe ich nie probiert.
Alkohol und Zigaretten?
Ja, aber Drogen?
Nee, nee, da habe ich mich nie dran getraut.
Gut.
Frau Krömer, haben Sie Allergen oder
Unversichtlichkeit, Unversichtlichkeit gegen die Personen?
Ja, also ich, ich habe so ein bisschen
so eine, so eine Empfindlichkeit bei Hausstaub.
Ja, also da muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich muss also die Betten oft beziehen und
und immer gut sauber machen und
also Hausstaub, ja, da kriege ich halt so ein bisschen Atemprobleme.
Atemprobleme.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch etwas Allergen?
Nee, sonst, sonst kann ich eigentlich alles vertragen, ja.
Okay.
Dann in Ihrer Familie gibt es bestimmte oder wichtigere Erkrankungen?
Ja, das weiß ich halt, alle haben.
Also mein Vater hatte, hatte auch schon diesen Alterszucker und
ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck und einer meiner Brüder, der hat auch
den Alterszucker genauso wie ich und
der andere Bruder, da weiß ich, dass, also der, der hat, der ist aber ja ein
bisschen jünger noch, der hat nur gesagt, dass er eben hohen
Blutdruck hat und das hatte eben mein Vater auch.
Ja, das scheint so in der Familie zu sein.
Ist Ihre Mutter gesund?
Ja, die lebt natürlich auch schon lange nicht mehr.
Es tut mir leid, zu hören.
Ja gut, ich bin 76, ja, wie alt müssen meine Eltern sein?
Also es ist ja nicht erstaunlich, dass die heute nicht mehr leben.
Okay, wissen Sie woran Ihre Mutter gestorben ist?
Ja, die haben damals gesagt, das wäre
irgendwie ein Herzproblem gewesen, dass die also so was wie einen Infarkt
gehabt hat oder so was, aber was da wirklich genau war, kann ich gar nicht sagen.
Okay.
Frau Krömer,
sind Sie vorständig geimpft wegen besonders
Kinderkrankheit oder Covid-19?
Kinderkrankheit ist ja schon eine ganze Weile her.
Also als Kind bin ich, ja, bin ich schon richtig geimpft worden.
Und ja, was ich jetzt auch gemacht habe,
natürlich, als diese große Corona-Geschichte war, da habe ich mich mehrfach impfen lassen.
Das hat man ja den alten Leuten empfohlen.
Und ja, zur Grippeimpfung gehe ich eigentlich auch jedes Jahr.
Im letzten Zeit,
waren Sie im Ausland?
Im Ausland?
Nee, also ich bin schon ewig nicht mehr weit verreist.
Ich war immer nur zu Hause oder eben hier so Freunde besucht, Kinder besucht.
Aber im Ausland war ich nicht.
Reiben Sie regelmäßig Spur?
Naja, in meinem Alter.
Also was ich tatsächlich noch mache, ich gehe einmal in der Woche,
gehe ich zum Square Dance.
Das ist so, dass man in so einer Reihe tanzt und das macht viel Spaß.
Und man ist unter Leuten und bewegt sich so ein bisschen nach Musik.
Und man muss ein bisschen sich konzentrieren.
Das tut mir ganz gut, ja.
Ja, sehr gut.
Frau Krabba, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin schon lange verwitwet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir hatten drei Kinder, aber die sind natürlich jetzt schon alle erwachsen.
Und die leben auch nicht alle hier in der Stadt.
Ein Kind lebt hier in der Stadt.
Die anderen sind auswärts.
Und ja, aber ich sehe die hin und wieder.
Aber ich lebe alleine.
Frau Krabba, vermute ich, dass Sie rennen.
Ja, ich bin schon lange im Ruhestand.
Was hat Sie gemacht früher?
Was ich vorher gemacht habe?
Ich war im Finanzamt tätig.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben
Alterszuckerkrankheit.
Ja, also diesen Alterszucker.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Krankheit?
Das hat man, glaube ich, so vor 15 Jahren.
15, 20 Jahre, schon lange eigentlich.
Ja, also
ich denke mal, ja, also wenigstens 15 Jahre schon.
Außer Zuckerkrankheit leiden Sie an anderen Krankheiten?
Ja, ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe ich natürlich auch.
Ja.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Ach, auch schon so.
Seit ich so Mitte 50 bin, das fing alles so an mit den Wechseljahren.
Ja, da wurde alles schlechter.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Als Kind habe ich natürlich die Mandeln rausbekommen und
was ist denn nochmal?
Ja, dann hatte ich mal
am Ellenbogen hatte ich so einen Schleimbeutel, aber das war nur so
eine kleine ambulante Operation, da konnte ich danach wieder nach Hause.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Also regelmäßig nehme ich das Metformin halt morgens und abends.
Und dann habe ich noch
für den oder gegen den hohen Blutdruck habe ich noch Ramipril.
Dann nehme ich morgens aber nur eine Tablette.
Also so ganz wild ist das nicht mit dem Blutdruck.
Wissen Sie die Dosierung?
Metformin und Ramipril?
Bei Metformin, das ist 1000.
1000 Milligramm und Ramipril?
Ramipril 5 ist das glaube ich.
Morgens.
Okay.
Dann Frau Kreml, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ich möchte kurz eine Zusammenfassung machen.
Sie haben seit ungefähr zwei Tagen
besonders
linksseitige Rückenschmerzen und ein bisschen Bauchbereich
und
sehr häufig Wasserlassen.
Ich muss sehr häufig Wasserlassen, ja.
Oh das schmerzt, ja.
Und auch ihre Wasserlassenfarbe ist ein bisschen dunkel.
Der Urin ja, der ist dunkel, genau.
Dunkel und stinkt.
Ja, riecht übel.
Und sie haben
Fiebergefühl, aber sie haben nicht gemessen.
Genau, das ist richtig.
Und ja, ist denen übel oder
übel oder schwindelig?
Also übel ist mir, ja aber schwindelig eigentlich nicht, nee.
Aber ich muss mich jetzt nicht übergeben oder so.
Also eigentlich ist das nur so
ja so eine allgemeine Schwäche und Krankheitsgefühl.
Haben Sie
Taupassgefühl oder Krippen im Bein?
Nein, nein, nein, nee, sowas habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, Ihre Hautfarbeveränderungen
im betroffenen Bereich besonders?
Ja, so habe ich jetzt nicht hingeguckt, aber
ich glaube nicht, dass die Haut eine andere Farbe hat, nein, nein.
Okay.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich will jetzt natürlich nur wissen,
wo das herkommt und was man dagegen tun kann, vor allen Dingen natürlich.
Ja, Frau Krummer, ich vermute, dass Sie eine
Harnreckeninfektion haben, aber es ist sehr früh etwas genau zu sagen.
Dann
werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen,
Blut- und Örenprobe abnehmen und
ein paar
ein paar andere Untersuchungen, zum Beispiel Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Ultraschall, das ist ja nicht schmerzhaft, ne?
Ja, Ultraschall ist keine schmerzhaftige Untersuchung
und hat keine Strahlen.
Das ist gut, ja.
Und da kann man auch schon was sehen, meinen Sie?
Ja, danach
wenn alle Informationen vorliegen, werde ich Ihnen schrittweise informieren.
Okay.
Bitte legen Sie auf die Liege, ich komme gleich.
Ja, okay, dann lege ich mich da schon mal hin.
Gut, ja, danke.
Okay, Sie sind hervorragend in der Zeit.
Ja, gerade ist die Uhr abgelaufen.
Sehr gut. Okay, möchte jemand noch was fragen?
Frau Krummer,
ist Ihnen ein vaginales Ausfluss aufgefallen?
Nee, ist mir gar nicht aufgefallen.
Nein.
Okay, haben Sie auch eine Nährestein Geschichte?
Früher schon mal, nee, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Danke.
Frau Krummer, haben Sie Erbrochen?
Nee, habe ich aber auch gerade gesagt.
Er hat ja nachgefragt nach Übelkeit und Schwindel.
Und da habe ich gesagt, ja, Übelkeit habe ich ja vorhin schon gesagt.
Aber ich musste mich nicht übergeben.
Ich musste nicht erbrechen.
Danke.
Ich habe das akustisch nicht gehört.
Haben Sie Veränderungen beim Stuhlgang bemerkt?
Na ja, also ich habe normalerweise immer ein bisschen Verstopfung
und da muss ich auch hin und wieder mal Medikamente nehmen.
Aber das ist jetzt in diesem Zusammenhang
ist nichts anders beim Stuhlgang.
Okay.
Aber man ehrlich ist, hat wahrscheinlich jede Frau
irgendwann mal Blasenentzündung gehabt und kennt das.
Aber jetzt so die mit solchen Schmerzen,
das hat sie noch nicht gehabt.
Sehen Sie das Mikro an.
Guten Abend, Frau Oberasten.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen und möchte Ihnen
diesen Falkurs vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich.
Können Sie ein bisschen näher ans Mikro?
Oh, ich höre Sie ein bisschen schlecht.
Okay.
Ja, danke.
Es geht um Frau
Natalia Grammer, die 76-jährige Patientin,
geboren am
4.88.1940.
Sie ist 1,78 Meter groß und
80 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen
seit zwei Tagen bestehender
progredienter linkseitiger Flankbereich Schmerzen.
Außerdem
vor, stellte sich vor.
Die Schmerzen strahlen
in den linkseitigen Oberschenkel aus.
In den linkseitigen Oberschenkel?
In den linkseitigen Oberschenkel aus.
Die Schmerzen sind
stickend, sehend und krampfartig.
Schmerzintestat liegt bei 6 bis 7 von 10 auf einer numerischen Skala.
Es gibt keine bestimmte Auslöser.
Sie hat Polylackerie, Dysurie, Fertig- und
Schütterfrost.
Sie hat Fibrilgefühl, aber nicht gemessen in ihren Körpertemperatur.
Und auch berichtete sie, dass
ihr Röhrchen ist ein bisschen dunkel und stinkt.
Oh ja.
Sie muss jede Stunde auf die Toilette gehen.
Auch nach jeder zwei Stunden muss sie auf die Toilette gehen.
Aber nur jetzt, sonst normalerweise nicht.
Ja, seit zwei Tagen hat sie diese Beschwerden.
Außerdem hat sie Nausea, aber
musste sie nicht Emesis.
Sie musste sich nicht übergeben oder beschreibt keine Emesis.
Fragen nach Atemnot, Husten,
Schwindelig,
Hautfarbeveränderungen,
neurologische Symptome wurden verneint.
In der Vegetative Anamnese
gab sie an, dass sie seit zwei Tagen wegen dieser Beschwerden in Appetanz und Insomnie.
Ja.
Sie hat
gegen Hausstaub allergisch.
Ist allergisch oder hat eine Allergie?
Wegen dieser Allergie
es äußert sich mit Atemproblemen.
Sie hat keine bestimmten Unfertigkeiten.
Der Impfstatus ist aktuell.
Reise an Anamnese ist unauffällig.
Als sportliche Aktivitäten tanzt sie einmal pro Woche.
Von einer Gruppe, ah ja, sehr schön.
In der Familienanamnese
ihre Vater
leidet an Diabetes mellitus Typ 2 und arteriöle Hpertonie.
Ihre Mutter
wegen einem
Myokartinfarkt,
hoffentlich eine Myokartinfarkt, gestorben.
Sie hat zwei Brüder, von denen
einen hat Diabetes mellitus Typ 2 und anderen leidet an arteriöle Hpertonie.
In der Noxon Anamnese
ist sie Raucherin.
Seit ungefähr 15 Jahren.
15?
15 Jahren
hat sie halbe Schachtel pro Tag geraucht.
Und davor raucht sie eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Oh ja.
Ungefähr 35 Jahre.
Sie trinkt abends täglich Rotwein und
mit einem Feier oder
Freunde treffen ein Glas Bier.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie ist verwitwet.
Hat drei Kinder.
Sie
wohne allein.
Ah ja, die Kinder sind wahrscheinlich erwachsen.
Ja, sie hat drei erwachsene Kinder.
Sie ist
derzeit Rentner.
Früher hat sie als Finanzamt tätig.
Beim Finanzamt, also sie war Angestellte im Finanzamt.
Das Finanzamt ist ja eine Behörde.
An Finanzamt, Angestellte.
An Vorerkrankungen leidet sie
an Diabetes Militus Typ 2 ungefähr 20 Jahren
und leidet sie an RTL-Hepatonie ungefähr 25 Jahren.
Sie würde bei ihr
als Kindheit eine Tonsillektomie durchgeführt und
eine
Ellenbogenpositis, wegen einer Ellenbogenpositis eine
Ambulanzophalaston durchgeführt.
Ah ja, okay.
Aber das war nicht in der Kindheit, ne?
Ja.
Sie nimmt regelmäßig mit vor mir 100.000
Milligramm morgens und abends und von April 5 Milligramm morgens ein.
Ja, Frau Oberarztin,
aufgrund der Analyse, ich gehe von einer
Pneumophilitis.
Was könnte es Differenzialdiagnostisch noch sein?
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen
Zysstitis, Dyschus prolaps oder Nierensteine.
Ah ja.
Nierensteine oder Neurodithiasis.
Ja, das kommt in Frage.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, werde ich
die Patientin zunächst körperliche Untersuchung,
Vitalparameter gemessen.
Ja, und worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich, ob Abwehrspannung,
Losdatschmerzen, Druckschmerzen vorhanden sind oder
in den Flankbereich eine Druckempfindlichkeit.
Ja, genau.
Gut. Und wonach schauen Sie noch?
Dann werde ich die Patientin Blut abnehmen und Urinprobe prüfen.
Welche Parameter lassen Sie labortechnisch bestimmen?
Ja.
Dabei würde ich Blutbildentzündungparameter
CRPBSG, Nierenwerte,
Leberwerte und Glukoswerte.
Ach ja, weil sie Diabetik sind.
Ja, genau.
Und auch
im Urin werde ich eine
Kultur veranlassen.
Was lassen Sie im Urin untersuchen?
Im Urin Untersuchung zunächst Mikroskopie, danach Urinkultur.
Ah, okay.
Gut. Wie geht es dann weiter, wenn Sie die Laborsachen auf den Weg
geschickt haben? Was kommt dann?
Danach werde ich
operative Maßnahmen durchführen.
Ja, und was liegt da als erstes?
Besonders
Abdomen-Sonographie oder
ich kann sagen besonders
Harnweg-Sonographie.
Ah ja, okay.
Und gegebenenfalls werde ich CT-Abdomen ohne Kontrast
durchführen oder?
Ja, okay, gut.
Wenn sich jetzt Ihre Vermutung bestätigt, was wäre denn für Sie die
angemessene Therapie? Was meinen Sie?
Ja,
sie hat keine
Fieber, aber sie hat Fiebergefühl.
Vielleicht hat sie eine Pyronephritis.
Ja, sollte sich meine Verlacht Diagnose als Pyronephritis bestätigen,
werde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen,
danach
werden wir Zugang legen und ausreichende Verlustigkeit zuvor.
Und als symptomatische Therapie
Analgetikum,
Spasmodikum,
Antipathikum und Antibiotikum.
Ja, also nicht richtig ordentlich Medikamente.
Gut, ja.
Gut, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was die Untersuchungsergebnisse
sind für die Frau Krämer und wenn Sie die tatsächlich stationär aufnehmen,
gucken wir heute Abend oder sonst im zweiten Morgen,
gucken wir uns die Patienten nochmal an und schauen dann, wie es ihr nach den
ersten Maßnahmen geht. Okay, gut.
Ja, ja, und auch nach den
Kulturen Ergebnisse werden wir die kalkulierte Antibiotherapie.
Dann haben wir eine erregerpassende.
Ja, ja, schön.
Ja, gut.
Herr Dr. Ates, das war ja ein Heimspiel für Sie, kann man sagen.
Sie waren in Ihrem Fachgebiet zu Hause.
Ja, da kann man, ich weiß es ja nicht vorher, was passiert.
Ja, es war für Sie natürlich insofern ein leichtes,
aber Sie haben sich auch so wirklich bravourös geschlagen, muss ich sagen.
Was mir sehr gut gefallen hat, dass Sie schon gleich von Anfang an sehr,
also einmal haben Sie die Patientin nett angesprochen, eine Winzigkeit.
Sie haben, ich habe einige persönliche Fragen.
Da zucke ich immer so ein bisschen zusammen.
Persönliche Fragen sind in unserem Sprachgebrauch
so private Fragen, ja.
Also eine persönliche Frage, was weiß ich, so,
ja, was wären das, sexuelle Vorlieben oder so was, das wäre was sehr
persönliches. Und das andere, ich habe Fragen zur Person.
Ja, das ist was anderes.
Persönliche Fragen sind eher so private Fragen.
Ich habe erst mal ein paar Fragen zur Person.
Ja, das ist ein winziger sprachlicher Unterschied.
Und
oder persönliche Daten, ja, das passt auch.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen zu Ihren persönlichen Daten.
Das kann man natürlich auch machen.
Aber wie gesagt, persönliche Fragen, das ist so ein bisschen privat.
Ja, gut.
Aber ansonsten war das wunderbar,
weil Sie die Patientin sehr schön angesprochen haben immer.
Und was mir super gut gefallen hat, Sie haben wirklich eine
eine vorbildliche Variation an Frage anfängen gehabt.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Also dieses ewige haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie absolut vermieden?
Und das war super.
Das hat mir richtig, richtig gut gefallen.
Von Anfang an hatte ich ja so ein
bisschen die Probleme, dass Sie sehr leise sprechen.
Aber das kommt natürlich auch,
das kommt sehr ruhig und sehr fokussiert drüber.
Und ich hatte zwar so von der Akustik manchmal Probleme, sie zu verstehen
oder musste sehr genau hinhören.
Aber diese sehr ruhige Art
kommt halt so beim Patienten gut an.
Ich fühlte mich gut aufgehoben, dass sie eben
nicht laut waren und so unaggressiv gefragt haben.
Das war sehr angenehm.
Und jetzt muss ich gerade überlegen, habe ich mir noch irgendwas aufgeschrieben?
Nee, da war nix.
So, und dann kam
was ich ein bisschen ungewöhnlich fand.
Das war ihre Reihenfolge, dass sie
erst die Familienanamnese gemacht haben
und dann nach den Vorerkrankungen und den Medikamenten gefragt haben.
Das ist ja, es ist so ein bisschen ungewöhnlich, weil normalerweise fragt
man ja nach den Vorerkrankungen unmittelbar nach der vegetativen Anamnese.
Das ist zumindest das Muster, was ich kenne, dass man dann sagt, ja,
was weiß ich, das und das sind jetzt ihre akuten Geschwerden.
Und gibt es denn bei Ihnen Vorerkrankungen?
Nehmen Sie Medikamente?
Und erst danach ist so im üblichen Ablauf die
die Frage nach familiärer Anamnese und dann auch nach sozialer Anamnese.
Aber das kann natürlich sein, dass das in Stuttgart unüblich ist und dass sie
eine andere Reihenfolge haben.
Es ist mir nur aufgefallen, sowohl beim Fragen als auch nachher beim
Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch, da haben sie es ja entsprechend analog auch gemacht.
Gut,
dann Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch war auch genauso schön ruhig, genauso
konsequent und natürlich
dieser Patient oder diese Patientin konnte Ihnen ja nichts vormachen, weil
das nun wirklich gerade ihr Fachgebiet ist.
Sie wussten genau, was mit der los ist.
Und sie haben dann ja auch der guten Ordnung halbe, haben sie sich ja auch
noch gefragt, ob sie Herz- oder Artebeschwerden hat.
Aber genau genommen wussten sie ja
eigentlich von vornherein, wo die Reise hingeht.
Das war ja ein offenes Geheimnis für sie.
Gut.
Dann ist nur auch wieder so eine winzige Sprachlichkeit,
Sprach,
red ich schon selber um, Entschuldigung, eine sprachliche Ungenauigkeit.
Die Frage nach schwindelig?
Nee, die Frage nach schwindeln.
Also ich hab sie auch ein paar Mal korrigiert, bei so Kleinigkeiten.
Da merkt man dann, dass sie beim
frei formulieren nicht ganz so sicher sind, wie beim Fragestellen.
Aber ich denke mal, das sind
kleine sprachliche Geschichten, die auch so ein bisschen dazu gehören.
Das ist ja auch, wenn jemand nicht ganz perfekt spricht,
das hat ja auch einen gewissen Charme, muss man sagen.
Und
ja, sie machen auch manchmal
diese Satzstellung, wie das praktisch fast alle nicht Muttersprachler machen.
Dann wir schauen nach ihrem Sowieso oder so.
Also dass das Verb eben dann nicht an zweiter Stelle steht.
Aber das ist einfach eine Kleinigkeit.
Aber ich hab das jetzt überhaupt nicht aufregend gefunden.
Und natürlich waren sie goldrichtig mit ihrer Pyelonephritis.
Und auch mit den ganzen
Untersuchungen, was mir ja,
es ist so ein Klassiker.
Sie haben Druckschmerz gesagt, Klopfschmerz,
Klopfschmerz im Rücken, das ist so der Klassiker, wo man nachfragt.
Und das sollte man vielleicht noch mit erwähnen.
Aber eben perfekt.
Ja, Blutuntersuchung, Urinstatus und
Urinkultur. Ja, was wollen wir mehr?
Und Therapie natürlich auch genau so, wie sie es gesagt haben.
Wunderbar. Also gehen Sie mit gutem Gefühl entspannt ins Wochenende
und dann auch in Ihre Prüfung.
Also selbst wenn Sie keinen urologischen Fall kriegen,
wird Ihnen glaube ich nicht viel passieren.
Gut, ja, ein vorbildliches Gespräch heute Abend.
Ich denke, wir haben alle auch
viel mitbekommen und viel daraus lernen können.
Herzlichen Dank allen, die wieder mitgemacht haben, zugehört haben.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen jetzt einen
netten Abend und ein schönes Wochenende, wenn es dann soweit ist.
Und wir sehen uns sehr gerne am Dienstag wieder.